prisonnier volontaire finalement parce
qu'on en a bien envie de ce progrès ce
qu'il faut s'en méfier c'est finalement
la question que pose ce film le gps
c'est merveilleux c'est vrai mais
sommes-nous prêts à payer le prix quel
est il d'ailleurs ce prix sommes nous
vraiment tout surveiller comment
protéger nos données personnelles comme
on dit faut-il avoir peur aussi du
piratage c'est d'actualité avec ce qui
s'est passé du côté de tv5 et puis est
ce qu'on peut continuer à dépendre d'un
système 100% américain aujourd'hui et où
en est le fameux projet européen de
diddy galileo le gps européen on va en
parler avec nos invités avec le
réalisateur du film frankie veut lier
avec la sénatrice ump catherine
procaccia vice-présidente de l'office
parlementaire d'évaluation des choix
scientifiques la géographe isabelle
sourbès-verger spécialiste des
politiques spatiales au cnrs nicolas
arpa gyan spécialiste en cyber sécurité
directeur scientifique à l'institut
national des hautes études de la
sécurité et de la justice je cite
également votre livre d'être l'auteur du
que sais-je sur la cybersécurité et puis
marilyn laurent qui est professeur en
sécurité informatique du côté de télécom
sudparis et auteur d'un livre qui
s'appelle la gestion des identités
numériques chez east j'ai bon east
édition parfait jusque là tout va bien
franck cuvelier d'abord qu'est ce qui
vous a pris d'abord de faire un
documentaire de vous lancer dans une
enquête comme ça sur le gps est ce que
quelque chose avait dit est ce que vous
aviez derrière l'oreille l'idée qui ce
que ça cache quelque chose qui avait un
loup non parce que j'étais naïf moi
j'avais un gps dans ma voiture et un
jour je me suis mis c'est formidable
c'est quand même incroyable on ne veut
plus jamais se perdre on est les
premiers dans l'humanité à être des
humains qui n'allons plus avoir la peur
de nous perdre et qui surtout en plus
qui allons avoir l'audace d'aller
quelque part
dans un endroit qu'on ne connaît pas est
ce qu'on fait on part en vacances on
part à thomas je suis du bateau ou par
lots ce titre c'est pas grave j'ai mon
gps ne retrouva bien j'arrive à bien me
localiser j'ai trouvé que c'était
formidable j'ai aucune aucune résistance
mais comment ces armes et la gloire du
gps au départ oui c'était vraiment
formidable avec l'idée que c'est
ah oui je pourrais merveilleux je
voulais savoir comment ça marchait
comment ça marche et merveilleux alors
il en interrogeant ce qu'ils font alors
ce qu'ils fabriquent et surtout ce qu'il
utilisait le développe là j'ai commencé
à avoir des doutes je me suis dit quand
même les cocos ils vont un peu fort
chez nokia et nous disent votre gps
c'est super on vous donne toutes les
routes quand il ya des ralentissements
c'est oui c'est vrai mais en même temps
on s'aperçoit que tous nos gps des
voitures bien son sont détectés ils ont
une tout le monde sait ou d'un gps se
trouve alors on ne sait pas que c'est
moi mais on le sait
finalement il ya une espèce de grande
connaissance de dd des positions de
chacun et la la j'ai commencé vous avez
équitable j'ai un portable sur votre
portable aussi on sait vous vous trouvez
oui je me quasiment tout le temps là je
m'en suis rendu compte mais alors j'ai
interrogé des gens qui m'ont sorti de ma
naïveté je pense
vous dit deux pages au gps illusion du
gps mouchard 10 à sion c'est big brother
le gps aujourd'hui là ça sert à ça oui
si on le veut bien je pense que s'il le
veut bien si vous si on ne scie on met
tous nos gps permet aussi on se laisse
faire oui on est on est géolocalisé mais
qu'est ce qu'est ce que ça peut faire de
savoir que moi personnellement je sois
quelque part ça aucune importance sans
aucune valeur que moi je souhaite
quelque part s de savoir que des
millions de vous sont quelque part ça
une utilité alors je crois que c'est de
savoir combien il ya de savoir n 2 où
des dizaines de milliers de vous dans
une manif par exemple exactement
pourrait avoir une telle pétition c'est
que je suis un journaliste quelque part
là du coup ça prend de la valeur si vous
pensez vous si on sait qu un journaliste
est quelque part aussi on sait qu'un
homme politique est quelque part si on
sait que avec un militant et quelque
part là tout de suite ça prend une autre
valeur mais ça se passe aujourd'hui ça
oui à l'espionnage par gps par
géolocalisation
je pense oui mais je pense mais je pense
que pense qu'on croise des informations
sur où on se trouve et qui on s est très
facile d'ailleurs un des chercheurs dans
le film qu'il explique très bien m'a
mangé mon téléphone je le pose sur ma
table de nuit il reste toute la nuit
n'ont même endroit si quelqu'un detec
mon téléphone il va se dire ce téléphone
qui dort là ils habitent là et donc qui
habitent là il suffit de prendre le
butin est on à mon adresse tout con le
numéro correspond à tel nom et l adresse
ci en plus de mains jouées
je vais l'hôpital me faire soigner du
diabète on sait que j'ai du diabète
parce qu'on verra bien jusqu'où aller
dans le département de diabétologie ou
jeu pourquoi donc on s'informe on empile
des informations sur qui je suis où je
suis comment schirck eu dix mois comme
on dit sûr que je te dirai qui tu es et
pour autant que vous avez toujours un
gps tout le temps web à savoir un
téléphone portable toujours je craque
quand vous n'êtes pas désintoxiquer non
parce que ça me donne trop davantage
d'avoir un gps on est drogué alors oui
on est rock et volontaire on dit que
c'est on dit que comme tous les drogués
qu'on maîtrise mais en fait je pense que
je ne maîtrise pas plus que les autres
mais je je je je me faut ma dose de gps
géo localisation une vie assisté par par
géolocalisation par un ordinateur même
et ses délicieux
comme quand finale suffisamment éclairé
n'avait pas fait un film pour dire je
vais partir en guerre contre le gpn
entre les grands méchants qui font de
l'argent c'est pas votre sujet nombre
d'objets c'est d'éclairer oui c'est de
se sortir d'un naïveté quoi bon j'étais
naïve je me suis rendu compte ça marche
ça marche pas comme je le croyais c'est
un peu plus compliqué il ya des intérêts
derrière il ya des des échanges c'est du
donnant-donnant quoi voilà si ça me
permet de draguer les filles un gps ou
traquer les garçons
je m'en sers c'est bien parce que il ya
des applications maintenant qui permet
de savoir où sont les gens qui ont envie
de faire des rencontres dans la revue
adam gontier 11 à la déception de la
jeune femme oui balle gps dit pato danon
est exactement mais bon en faisant ça on
devient quelqu'un qui se déclare comme
étant un célibataire en recherche ou
alors nommé rien recherche mais voyez
c'est ici un jeu donc on informe le
monde de qui on est qu'elles sont dans
intentions et nos sentiments du moment
donc il faut le savoir je comprends
votre démonstration ça vous dérange
qu'on dépendent pour ça des américains
l'enjeu de l'avenir pour vous c'est le
développement d'un gps européen je veux
dire alors moi je n'ai pas en tant que
citoyen
au départ j'ai cru
je vais faire sortir de leurs gongs
certains certaines personnes autour de
cette table je pense mais au début j'ai
cru que c'était une bonne idée de
s'affranchir du gps américain en disant
il faut notre propre système c'est
normal le rôdeur son système et shiloh
avant le leur il faut une indépendance
on peut pas tous dépendre d'eux
oui mais je suis moins convaincu du
finalement est ce qu'il y avait un seul
gps bien fichu que tout le monde
partageait ce serait pas plus
intéressant et plus simple à faire
fonctionner merci de m'avoir c'est le
débat qu'on va avoir ensemble
effectivement et j'envoie noter qu'ils
ne sont pas forcément d'accord avec ce
que vous venez de dire c'est le moins
qu'on puisse dire dernière question ça a
changé votre façon d'utiliser votre
portable vous avez gardé un portable et
garder un gps parce qu'on a changé votre
façon de l'utiliser pas du tout pas du
tout non même n'est pas même rentrer
dans les coordonnées ou dans les
réglages de confidentialité de votre
portable un peu plus ou non non non non
j'avoue je blesse prendre j'ai trop de
dellys l'utiliser je confesse voilà
merci pour ce film en tout cas qui
montrent notamment que les fermiers
américains sont les meilleurs vrp du gps
regardez
ring ce que nous faisons dans ma ferme
c'est collecter de plus en plus de
donner
un bol par exemple pour ceux nés au
printemps je travaille maintenant avec
un système qui compile 20 couches de
données
humilité d fertilité du sol et tous les
types de fertilité
comme ça je sais tous les trois mètres
dans mon champ ce qui doit être corrigé
ce qui fonctionne c'est qu'il faudra
changer l'année suivante pour que je
sois encore plus efficace au final sur
mon exploitation
c'est comme récolté de l'or parce que
ces données val de l'eyre
oui ça vaut de l'or d'ailleurs le film
démontre que des gens font de l'or aussi
avec bon quelle est votre position
catherine progressé à vous pensez que le
gps est une bonne chose tout court un
progrès points je suis très proche de la
position du réalisateur du malin
la seule chose sur laquelle je ne suis
pas d'accord c'est de dire qu' un seul
gps au monde suffit parce que quand on
dépend d'un seul gps d'un seul système
eh bien on dépend justement et l'état et
quel que soit l'état peut le coupé quand
il veut et ce que n'ont pas fait les
américains
et 9 satellites al yah dire oui il ya
des zones qu'il ne donne pas par exemple
je ne sais désape l'essai des zones
militaires sur lesquels le gps ne passe
pas et quelquefois y compris quand nous
avons des cathares et il ya des
catastrophes naturelles dans le monde le
gps américain ne permet pas de donner
des informations et ce sont les
satellites d'autres pays qui lui donne
parce que pour par rapport aux intérêts
et aux intérêts de chacun des états vous
avez des zones qui sont
qui ne sont pas couvertes ou moins
couverts ou tout simplement peu
couvertes par ce que ce n'est pas très
intéressant d'avoir lu lé ps dans un
endroit où il ya très peu d'habitants
donc vous êtes galileo oui il faut le
développer un jeu dit kazim civile oui
tout à fait c'est la grande différence
c'est pas c'est pas si c'est pas
militaire et deuxièmement vous avez
évoqué au début
le bas ce qui est arrivé à tv5 ce qui
peut arriver partout je veux croire que
je crois qu'il est indispensable qu'on
est plusieurs systèmes qui vont être
d'ailleurs des systèmes qui vont pouvoir
communiquer les uns avec les autres
parce qu'imaginez
une attaque informatique de grande
ampleur sur le gps mais il ya plus gps
américain ou sur le gps russe il n'y a
plus rien qui fonctionne il ya plus de
trains n'y a plus d'avion hier ce n'est
pas simplement notre géolocalisation
pour savoir si on prend la route à
droite au mobile le mup ouais c'est pas
ça oui c'est tout le reste c'est un
enjeu stratégique et le fait d'avoir
plusieurs udps et bien on pourra aider
les américains ou les russes si
nécessaire toutes façons les
boulangeries où le pain au point
d'ailleurs le chaînon des chinois
pas encore mais ils le seront mais 300
je sais pas quel pourra être la
communication avec les chinois qui est
quand même toujours un petit peu
difficile mais je pense que c'est de la
sécurité de ne pas dépendre de quelqu'un
imaginez alors je ne sais pas si ça
s'est passé mais sur l'ukraine
que l'ukraine ne soit couverte que par
les américains on peut parler russe eh
bien on aurait peut-être en pet de
conflits pas pu savoir ce qu'il est je
suis pas sûr que le gps fonctionne
fonctionner à cuba peut-être qu'il
fonctionnera même si on va à cuba que
pour le tourisme mais en même temps
c'est pour géolocaliser des personnes
qui peuvent avoir des accidents c'est
pour retrouver un bon nombre de
personnes donc je crois
je crois que quand l'europe pour une
fois a pris une décision mais arrive à
dire combien de temps rappelez moi on
jean vincent a décidé de lancer son
système autonome et civils
et que après toutes les difficultés
financières on vient le budget est un
budget purement union européenne eh ben
ça je crois que c'est une bonne chose
pour la fiabilité de notre vie
quotidienne j'entends isabelle
sourbès-verger j'imagine que vous êtes
d'accord avec ça combien ça coûte des
vidéos en fait moi je suis d'accord avec
ça j'ai juste un petit peu d'amusement
par rapport à ce qu explique le
réalisateur au début parce que qui n'a
pas eu dans sa voiture un gps qui l'a
mal aiguillé mais qu'il envoyait sur une
fausse route
ok tu es tu et qui s'obstine à vous dire
que tourner à gauche alors que bonds qui
n'a pas eu un gps qui n'est pas capable
de vous donner précisément leuthard et
le problème des ultras fille qu'ils ont
goûté ya donc là dessus moi je suis papa
tout à fait convaincre que ce serait un
peu mieux non c'est pas que ça va être
mieux c'est que je pense qu'en fait le
système a des failles et là je vais me
souvenir du plan de banlieue y compris
dans wii alors vous savez ça c'est assez
assez étonnant parce que vous avez des
gens qui vous disent que effectivement
avec une carte ils sont quand même
parfois beaucoup plus sûr qu'avec un gps
parce que c'est la carte est bien fait
ils n'ont aucune raison de se perdre le
problème de la carte si elle est pas
mise à jour ou si vous savez pas la lire
ou si vous savez pas où vous êtes au
départ mais le gps ne vous donne pas
quand même la totalité de l'interface le
gps vous guide mais c'est aussi quelque
chose qui vous contraint beaucoup donc
danser
mais beaucoup d'intérêt de faire un gps
européen mais pas pour forcément les
raisons de demander combien ça coûte et
oui alors je sais pas combien sa finale
java kumala pour l'instant on est à 7
oui 7 milliards oui c'est ça mais
le programme est là au début à trois
milliards et demi donc il en est pas
pressé on leur à caen mais en fait la
question si vous voulez c'est amusant
2018 oui complet opérationnel ce qui est
amusant c'est par exemple on vous dit
sur le site de l'union européenne quand
il veut et toutes ces difficultés de
financement mais finalement galileo
c'est pas très cher ses 150 km
d'autoroutes périurbaines on dit que ces
2 euro par européen alors 150 km
d'autoroutes périurbaines après tout
vous vous dites ça fasse idea
circulation etc et c'est une image
complètement fausse parce que une
autoroute périurbaines vous n'êtes pas
obligés de renouveler au même titre et à
la même rapidité le goudron que les
satellites vous avez pas deuxième
segment parce que la galilée où vous
avez le segment sol et vous avez le
segment spatial il faut que les deux
fonctionnent bien pour que le système
marche et puis derrière et ça c'est la
grande question pour tous les systèmes
de gps et la géolocalisation sait quels
sont les bénéfices induits comment vous
allez calculer les réelles économies que
vous allez réaliser parce que
effectivement en cadrant cas alors le
sait le cas emblématique mais d'une aide
humanitaire vous allez pouvoir
effectivement avec beaucoup plus de
facilité guider vos camions et cetera et
cetera dans les problèmes de gestion
tout ce qui est catastrophe naturelle
c'est quand même quelque chose d
extrêmement efficace mais ça allait
aussi d'un point de vue militaire on en
reparlera peut-être et puis d'un point
de vue civil qui compte que prend le but
d'un point de vue militaire redisons le
si l'armée américaine décide de nous
couper l accès au gps ou de le dégrader
elle va faire une excuse la vie quand
effectivement il y avait des offensives
qui ne lui convenait pas alors elle n'a
pas dit non vous ne pouvez pas aller sur
le terrain a dégradé le signaler en
dégradant le signal vous avez un des
états majors qui à ce moment-là n'assume
plus des opérations parce qu'il ya un
trop grand degré d'incertitude
c'est pour ça que ce caractère civil et
militaire il est déterminant pourquoi
est-ce que galileo n'est pas militaire
pas par essence des européens parce
qu'il ya eu un veto des britanniques et
des néerlandais et on peut considérer
que les britanniques et les néerlandais
étaient pas totalement innocent dans
cette affaire pourquoi parce que ça pose
le problème du financement
l'avantagé quand vous avez des clients
militaires ce sont des clients qui
payent toute l'année sur toutes les
zones du monde donc quand vous faites
votre modèle économique notre business
model c'est très bien d'avoir des
clients militaires parce que ce sont des
qu'ils disent attendait la crise elle
est partout moi j'ai ma zone de
chalandise il y en a sept en afrique
donc c'est en asie et donc quand vous
réunissez tous ces pays autour de la
table vous arrivez à couvrir le monde
est à vous trouver un modèle de
financement à partir du moment où vous
dites non on exclut les militaires on ne
fait que des marchés civils vous avez
affaire à des gens qui vous disent pas
premier âge pas pour le club
méditerranée je veux pas d'un homme qui
peut être intéressé de services gps avec
le mail il va être intéressé pour
certains pays certains moments de
l'année à certaines phases donc il va
falloir quand vous montez le budget
trouver des clients qui sont intéressés
partiellement dans l'année sur certaines
zones il avait demandé zone qui
n'intéresse personne seule pour laquelle
c'est l'union européenne c'est une
entité politique
ses services et que j'allais vous
émettez dans la logique militaire dès
l'origine on aurait certainement pu
comment dire résoudre ou en tout cas à
amoindrir les problématiques financières
pardonnez moi je voudrais quand même
délivré que de trois informations mehdi
2018 nous aurons à galileo c'est-à-dire
un gps européen en état de fonctionner
oui oui qui va alimenter donc qui serait
pas la différence quand ça changera t il
devrait être plus wha plus précise il
devrait sur le monde entier ou sur
l'europe sur le monde entier way sur le
monde entier bon mais l'horizon sur la
part gratuit alors c'est toute la
question actuelle du gps de vous payer
non gratuit aujourd'hui c'est bien ce à
quoi je
suis ça continuera à être gratuit sauf
précisément parce que vous évoquez
savoir le service payant qui
représenteront un plus parce qu'il y
aura une application associés pour de la
lhjmq sont des grandes aux prix
maintenant sont gratifiés si vous voulez
c'est gratuit sans est gratuit mais là
je pense que c'est un économiste qui
vous diraient non pardon quand vous
achetez une montre pour faire le
marathon paris par exemple sur votre
système garmin vous avez une petite puce
gps qui vous permet de vous localiser en
utilisant à la fois le système russe
c'est intéressant glonass et le système
américain gps donc c'est clair il n'y a
pas de problème de géopolitique des
croisés et c'est bon il est bien évident
que le fabriquant garmin lui ils paient
des redevances d'une manière ou d'une
autre aux gens qui distribuent donc si
vous voulez ce système il est gratuit
dans sa distribution mais ensuite vous
avez des entités qui refont interface
internet domaine bernard et d'une
manière générale oui si vous voulez la
question et c'est pour ça que c'était
très important d'avoir un gps et un
système de navigation européen c'est la
diversité des applications à venir alors
on n'en parle pas mais par exemple
l'aviation on parle un jour de supprimer
les balises sol
si vous supprimez les balises seul il
faut que votre système de gps soit
absolument totalement performant parce
que c'est bien beau d'avoir la
performance je dirais en termes de
positionnement sur le sol mais la
positionne le positionnement en altitude
on comprend bien que pour des avions qui
vont atterrir c'est encore plus cruciale
or là dessus si vous avez un seul
système système américain imaginer ce
qu'on appelle les problèmes de météo
solaire 1 c'est-à-dire tout à coup il ya
un problème entre une émission solaire
un petit peu trop forte ça brûle les
ondes votre système gps et décroît votre
fiabilité les plus des rentiers votre
avion qui se crashe donc on a tous
intérêt d'une certaine façon à ce qu'il
y ait plusieurs systèmes combinés aux
américains y compris bien sûr j -
quentin et nous avec et c'est l'intérêt
commun d'avoir un seuil d'opération ce
qu'on appelle interopérables parce que
le système se corrige mutuellement alors
après bien évidemment le système
américain il avait une originalité ces
deux types de balises la balise civile
et la balise militaire si vous aviez une
balise de type militaire vous aviez un
signal spécifique de type militaire qui
vous donner une précision beaucoup plus
grand combien pour acheter ou au ça
pouvait être à moins d'un mètre - doit
être ça peut être même je pense qu'en
tout fait des opérations très spécial ça
doit être vraiment une précision très
très fine bon on a pas forcément de
source là dessus on va dire qu'à moins
d'un mètre c'est déjà très bien et avec
cette nouvelle pardonna pas ça veut dire
par exemple que la cia a pu mais pas pu
réaliser à rennes laden est dans la
maison
on connaît s'il pouvait vous avez vu la
guerre le problème c'est qu'il faut que
ben laden ait eu un téléphone portable
allumé si
compliqué en revanche vous l'avez vu au
moment de la première guerre du golfe
tout le monde à admirer la précision des
frappes des missiles américains elle
était guidée par gps là c'est absolument
évident et quand on va détruire une
antenne bien spécifique on a une
précision très très très grande donc ce
qu'ont fait les américains sur le gps et
qu'ils se sont engagés à garder un
système civil ouvert avec une résolution
on va dire moyenne est en revanche ils
ont vendus ou échangés ont prêté 20 des
balises magali terre d'où les problèmes
en yougoslavie qui font que un certain
nombre par exemple pour le tracé de la
frontière c'est vrai que les militaires
français se sont plaints de ne pas avoir
reçu à temps les fameuses balises gps
qui leur aurait permis de participer bon
ca de l'intérêt d'avoir un système à
nous placer croisées avec d'autres et
plus précis me disiez vous que l'actuel
système que les américains offrent aux
civils j'ai résumé là c'est bien sauf
l'euro sur galets fait ça voudrait dire
un mot du piratage parce que c'est
important vous qui connaissez la
sécurité sur le bout des doigts ce qui
s'est passé sur tv5 apparaît par exemple
un piratage d'antenne ça peut se passer
sur le gps américain on peut prendre le
contrôle des 29 satellites américains
qui sont au dessus de nos têtes et qui
assure notre gps je ne serai pas oui je
pense effectivement c'est assez
compliqué à mettre en oeuvre mais c'est
pas impossible c'est un système
d'information donc qui des systèmes
d'information pénétrer et il faut garder
à l'esprit si on a le cas de la sphère
snowdon également c'est vous avez
l'attaqué extérieur et l'attaquent de
l'intérieur c'est à dire qu'un agent un
salarié du réseau qui a décidé pour des
raisons militante pour des raisons
crapuleuses pour plein de motifs qui
peuvent lui être propres de prendre la
main sur le système ce qui est certain
c'est que il faut par contre se pose est
donc comme c'est un système
d'information système informatique qui
n'a jamais été conçu pour être sécurisé
l'informatique c'est une technologie
faut garder ça à l'esprit c'est
extraordinaire ça non non non scellées
pour découvrir mais non regardez la
farine a construit les ordinateurs en
disant ya pas de pirates bien sûr que
non puisque l'idée qu'il y avait c'est
une industrie est si on prend l'analogie
avec l'aviation l'aviation que lorsque
boeing lorsque airbus mais tu enlèves
met en l'air des avions il est steen qui
doit être sûr à 99,9 9 9 9 9 %
al'inverse vous prenez une maisons
prestigieuses comme microsoft microsoft
depuis 40 ans à peu près fait une fois
par mois ce qu'il appelle le patch
tuesday donc le pansement du mardi et il
corrige ses erreurs du mois et des
erreurs que l'on signalé ses
utilisateurs ça fait 40 ans que i
corrige il met un bout de rustines un
bout de pansements passé le bug
pardonnez moi mais ça imaginez qu'ils
aient pu mais pas costil mais non parce
que le problème c'est que ça reste des
compositions nommé ce que dira pas assez
qu'on peut pas miser sur une étanchéité
je conviens assureraient sa sécurité
ben oui mais c'est la raison pour
laquelle la même manière lorsque les
américains ont ce fameux drones predator
cette espèce de le meux comment dire
bijou de technologie qui peut à la fois
tiré peu à la fois prendre des images
qui est piloté à partir du sol américain
pour intervenir en irak en afghanistan
rabon il s'avère que pendant très
longtemps le il ya eu un moment un
moment de flottement de la part de
l'état major américain parce que ils
n'avaient ils n'arrivaient plus à
trouver de rebelles à les gens ils
n'arrivaient plus à les trouver au sol
ils se disent c'est marrant on n'arrive
plus à les localiser à savoir où ils
sont pourquoi parce qu'il s'avère que le
flot de messages qui partait du drone
predator jusqu'au centre de commandement
n'étaient pas cryptés et manifestement
moyennant un petit logiciel qui
s'appelle skygrabber qui est un truc qui
vaut quelques dizaines par la petite
centaine de dollars vous pouviez
intercepté ce flux et qu'est ce qui
s'est passé c'est que le gars au sol il
a intercepté le flux mais c'est pas par
mesquinerie puisque predator l'unité
vaut plusieurs millions de dollars c'est
un bijou de technologie vont rentrer bon
simplement on n'avait pas crypté le flux
parce qu'on s'était dit bah non les gens
qui seront au sol il savait pas alors il
ya peut-être à l'attaché militaire qui a
opportunément qui ont indiqué aux gens
au sol la petite méthode d'eau et le
petit logiciel qui l'a bien et
maintenant à posteriori on a dit ah au
fait on va cryptée ce qui est
techniquement la même affaire le
problème est que celle que la sécurité
informatique à l'interview généralement
comme la dernière roue du carrosse
d'ailleurs convenu au départ que le
système fonctionne d'accord pour qu'un
système fonctionne on n'a pas envie
d'être embêté ennuyé par un certain
comment dire des règles de sécurité des
dispositifs de ccra lentilles qui sont
parfois lourds et et donc c'est vrai que
la première des choses comme pour
l'internet où tout démarrage s'était pas
sécurisé d'accord c'était un réseau pour
les chercheurs c'est un réseau militaire
passé tout en gardant l'utilisateur de
bonne foi voilà exactement
et petit à petit bassin c'est
complètement ouvert donc la société se
les accaparer avec mad à ces dérives
avec des problèmes un certain nombre de
valeurs et des failles des intérêts
économiques des intérêts
par le biais de fraude pouvoir gagner un
peu d'argent etc oui des failles qui
sont mises en place les systèmes
informatiques ne sont pas dénués de
faille donc effectivement c'est c'est un
problème c'est un temps additionnel plus
de complexes 50 ans nous entend vous
avez raison ça marche turque à moitié
pourraient connaître parce que ça veut
dire que notre système aussi nous celui
qu'on utilise même s'il peut être tenté
ce qu'on peut en fait en tant que
je dis qu'il ya des failles mais tous
les jours les systèmes sont patchés
enfin il ya des efforts qui sont faits
mais c'est pas infaillible on y voit sa
tâche dans une correction que d'en avoir
une solution le pansement aux halles il
ya 30 ans c'est vraiment prendre le
préventif à ses poursuites
et oriana
ressortir une commission justement entre
l'assemblée le sénat hier la sécurité
numérique c'est vrai ce qui est vous
avez un système préventif absolument
extraordinaire vous avez un ordinateur
qui parlent via internet là vous avez
essayé de lui mieux ravailler avec ça
mais c'est juste l'inconvénient
c'est absolument passionnant ce que vous
décrivez ce point slam à deux secondes
sur le jury a nommé soldats et l'ont
signé sur le gps et tous vous intéresse
j'en suis sûr mais pour comprendre
pourquoi l'objectif militaire fait qu'on
veut aller vite et pas s'embarrasser
m'avez vous dit de règles de sécurité
latéral est excessif je caricature favre
notamment l'enjeu économique fait qu'on
veut aller vite il ya de très gros enjeu
économique on va le voir maintenant
autour de ce qu'on appelle le mapping
google google car ça vous dit sans doute
quelque chose regarder
c'est très important pour les gens
d'avoir des cartes à jouer vous pourriez
vous demander pourquoi la raison c'est
que les gens se fient de plus en plus
aux produits et aux services qu'ils
utilisent ces cartes et que le monde
réel change considérablement
nous faisons 2,7 millions de
modifications tous les jours les gens
comptent sur des réponses exactes quand
il cherche quelque chose
voilà ça c'est l'enjeu absolument
formidable que représente le le mapping
juste une précision parce que je
voudrais que les choses soient claires
qu'on pense pas que tout peu le nôtre
mais on peut sombrer du jour au
lendemain est-ce qu'on peut oui ou non
je repose la question que vous posez
tout allait reprendre le contrôle des 29
satellite américain qui m'a si
aujourd'hui mon signal gps n'ont
sûrement pas sous cette forme des
satellites non des satellites non les
satellites sont plus que cryptée ils
sont plus que blindés ils sont rentrés
le sperme des prendre le contrôle en le
satellite qui est quand même à quelques
milliers de kilomètres dizaines de
milliers de kilomètres de la terre n'ont
en revanche pas beaucoup plus simple
c'est ce qu'on vous explique c'est à
dire de récupérer l'information quand
elles arrivent au sol et dans un système
spatial mais c'est valable aussi pour
observation de la terre et pour tout les
télécoms regardez ce qui est arrivé à
tv5 c'est au moment de la réception et
au moment de la transmission du signal
que vous pouvez agir c'est pas sur la
plateforme elle-même voilà ça c'est dit
ce qu'on vient de voir son des
entreprises qui s'arrachent ce secteur
incroyable qui est celui du donc du
mapping or je vais le dire en français
de la cartographie la photographie de la
confection des d'écarter sa part
forcément à la géographe que vous n'êtes
pas
ça ça vous choque ou d'ailleurs est ce
que ça vous choque que ce soit à vendre
moi j'aime bitat à côté de sa maman d&g
l'hygiène est bien léger elle sa mission
de faire les cartes et de les vendre et
complètement bouleversé avec l'institut
géographique national
le métier n'est plus le même les cartes
ne sont plus les mêmes et vous parlez
des cartes que ce soit y compris quand
on fait de la marche à pied ou du vélo
et bien tout ça ça a bouleversé
l'économie de la cartographie et sabots
verts des entreprises mais de très
grosses entreprises sont entrées en jeu
de très gros marché sont développés et
par ailleurs sacré d'autres emplois oui
on va peut-être
là le cnes on va peut-être travailler
avec google il est spécial le centre
nommé oui vous devez tout à fait pour
puisque google a la prétention de
pouvoir couvrir la planète en juillet on
s'échappe des américains vidéo on y
retrouve de l'autre côté bien sûr mais
il ya ceux qui étaient positionnées
avant nous sur ce type de sept membres
parce que le segment de la cartographie
par gps c'est pas l'europe qu'il
inventait non et quand même je veux dire
on a bénéficié pendant plus de vingt ans
d'un système totalement gratuit payés
par le contribuable américain donc je
veux juste dire que les gens disent non
mais c'est même pas la question c'est
juste quelque chose qu'on a un tout
petit peu oublié et sans eux on aurait
certainement pas évolué comme on l'a
fait on aurait peut-être même pas
forcément pensé à faire notre système
qu'on a un peu de retard humains oui
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que
pendant la guerre froide les russes ont
fait la même chose pour les mêmes
raisons militaires étaient en fait de la
précision de localisation au moment des
opérations et qu' ils ont eu à coeur de
remettre très tôt leur système or ça a
été vraiment le programme fédéral par
excellence du président poutine quand il
est arrivé en 2001 il a mis jusqu'en
2011 pour arriver à ses fins mais il a
un système et c'est ça qui me paraît
quand même intéressant dans le débat
d'aujourd'hui dont il vise
essentiellement à un usage civil et une
rentabilité économique donc c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui tous les systèmes de
navigation ont basculé du côté d'un
modèle gare et économique autonome mais
c'est pas vraiment une guerre à l'est et
les russes le voit beaucoup plus comme
une manière justement d'avoir un outil
d'influencé ils ont signé très tôt des
partenariats avec les indiens ils ont
signé des partenariats avec les chinois
et c'est une manière de contre balancer
une influence américaine dans d'autres
parties du monde et c'est important que
l'europe soit encore elle aussi capable
de proposer un autre type de modèle et
du et construisent un système civil au
départ mais là il y aura des duels là on
est sur le plan stratégique et
économique azim en mondial est pour moi
et pour mes petites données personnelles
comment est ce que je fais avec tout ça
est ce que ça fait de moi dans cette
espèce d'univers incroyable fantastique
incroyable parfois un peu inquiétant est
ce que ça fait de moi une cible
marketing permanente
effectivement on est géolocalisé nos
données de géolocalisation font objet de
beaucoup des changes sur le réseau
typiquement par exemple nous avons
plusieurs relevés de géolocalisation qui
sont effectués par minute depuis notre
smartphone donc à notre insu c'est à
dire que typiquement facebook chez à peu
près chaque minute de notre temps où
nous sommes si je voulais je le fais
entrer je me sui ger lequel il est bien
sûr si j'ai activé mon
ceci dit le gps est une source de
géolocalisation et y en a d'autres huit
mois d'accord le wifi en et une par
exemple d'accord on peut oser localiser
une personne
s'il a laissé son comment dire son wifi
ouverts on peut aussi j'ai localiser une
personne par le biais des opérateurs
mobiles et par l'utilisation du réseau
et voilà était la population exactement
relation est donc voyez le gps n'est pas
la seule source de géolocalisation mais
vous me confirmer qu'on est à ce que je
dois dire piste et oui oui oui oui
crasse et tout à fait mais c'est des
modes de financement quand facebook ne
dis pas que c'est mal en soi on est
plutôt volontaire
c'est le mode de financement c'est à
dire que le problème c'est que la
monétisation pour que facebook à l'offre
son service elle dit voilà il doit le
vendre à des annonces les annonceurs
c'est quelqu'un qui fait que moncef il
doit faire connaître un produit mais il
est encore plus satisfait si vous
l'achetez se produisent ce service est
donc il a besoin de l'adapter
géographiquement et donc effectivement
le contrat moral site noter qu'on puisse
parler de contrats et de morale en
l'espèce c'est de dire dites moi qui
vous êtes et c'est pour ça par exemple
que facebook lutte contre les
pseudonymes de manière à ce qu'il voit
comme étant une barrière à
l'identification parce que pour lui
c'est important de savoir qui vous êtes
parce qu'il va pouvoir le monétiser ou
insalubres naceur évidemment c est donc
c'est vos déplacements pardonnez moi le
modèle de financement de facebook ben
c'est de la pub c'est la revente de
données nous l'ont alors l'un va avec
l'autre puisque il va valoriser si vous
fréquentez doute parce que c'est le
réseau
ou vous fréquentez autres savent à
catégoriser votre niveau social les
votre niveau de vie vos centres
d'intérêts et donc on va voir si vous
revois bien que vous passez comme c'est
bien connu vos vacances d'été à saint
tropez ah bon vous êtes à chamonix
divers et vous êtes à peu près dans les
îles entre noël et le jour de l'an hu la
chance voilà c'est ce que dit en tout
cas votre relevé gps et revenir à la
télé comme il est évident que vous
n'êtes là on n'a pas vous n'avez pas
besoin de savoir plus sur la personne
oui effectivement elle a un train de vie
si fx est donc évidemment c'est des
mesures d'identification alors mais en
revanche ces fichiers vous le confirmer
on les voit aux annonceurs comme étant
des profits luzia ordinaire des
propriétés un camion moelleux la revente
de fichiers non mais de la même manière
et et non mais comme un journal va
vendre un peu comme pour une régie
publicitaire qui va dire mes lecteurs
mais deux auditeurs mais téléspectateurs
ce sont des cadres ou n'est pas avec le
rayon et leur profil facebook mais sa
ville c'est ce que permet la technologie
après quels sont les dessous real c'est
difficile de savoir qu'est-ce qu'on
croise les fichiers oui c'est possible
de croiser des fichiers oui je encore
émission de radio canada a appris que
c'était interdit en fait il faut
comprendre c'est que même si sous
couvert d'anonymat certaines
informations étaient transférés à des
tiers à des sociétés qui récupère un
certain nombre de données de données
même anonymisées il faut comprendre que
si vous prenez deux bases de données
donc deux fichiers qui sont anonymisées
en les croisant il est possible de réis
densifier les personnes et c'est là où
il ya vraiment le vrai danger
l'incroyable et donc c'est vrai qu'au
niveau de la commission européenne il ya
tout un travail qui est actuellement
fait en particulier sur le domaine de
l'internet des objets tous ces petits
objets connectés qui nous entoure
essayez de comprendre en fait les
interactions les implications cela va
avoir pour l'utilisateur et est en fait
le débat en fait se joue sur ces données
anonymisées est-ce que
est
ce qu'une donnée personnelle finalement
quand elle est anonymisé il faut la
tourner a considéré comme étant
personnels et à ce moment là on reste
dans le cadre de la législation
européenne des données personnelles avec
les traitements qui sont très encadrées
ou est-ce qu'on en sort et à ce moment
là c'est là tout l'enjeu de considérer
des données comme réellement anonymisées
vous voyez donc il ya une grosse
différence entre les deux je comprends
surtout je suis anonymes comme cela
quand c'est sur un fichier et que je ne
le suis plus quand il y en a deux ou
trois exactement croisés c'est
intéressant parce que cette émission est
sûre le gps et la géolocalisation
évidemment ce que vous décrivez c'est
beaucoup plus large c'est beaucoup mais
mais mais c'est bien ça quand j'ai
acheté dans un magasin désormais il ya
petit nid du magasin sur mon facebook
vous êtes apte ce magasin on ne sait pas
ce que je suis acheté dans croisement de
fichiers on peut le savoir c'est ça le
principe du gc ca le principe oui mais
par contre ce qui est intéressant c'est
que voyez il ya un modèle de voitures
autonomes ces voitures qui peuvent se
conduire elle même qui vient d'être
annoncé par valeo et par safran ça
s'appelle drive for youth et la non de
ce modèle et son un de ses arguments
commercial à 7 à cette voiture c'est
qu'elle n'a pas de gps à bord c'est un
système dunaire c'est extraordinaire
c'est un art you et ils vous disent très
clairement aux non c'est comme une
personne ya 20 ans disant ceci n'est
qu'un téléphone exactement parce que là
on parle d'une toile ce ciné novo est on
parle bien une voiture autonome doté
d'une voiture bourrée de technologie on
n'est pas dans la régression ou dans la
lah le sacrifice technologique
simplement alors elle fonctionne par
inertie c'est à dire en fait c'est sont
ces mouvements qui lui permettent de se
repérer par rapport à son point de
départ mais dans son argumentaire de
présentation de ce modèle qui a été fait
courant il ya quelques jours en mars
2015 c'est vraiment de dire il n'y a pas
de gps et donc par contre évidemment
vous êtes localiser avec ce boubou et
vous repérer automatiquement avec ce
système notamment de guidage par avec
l'inertie de la voiture cette centrale à
inertie est par contre on évite le
piratage on évite les zones les tunnels
où vous êtes justement où le gps peut
pas le mal passé et effectivement c'est
un élément de c'est un élément de
valorisation de la technologie c'est ce
que fait valeo et safran justement pour
dire voilà avec ma voiture vous aurez
vous aurez cette condition que vous
soyez pas dedans avec un téléphone
portable
bien se former
donc vous prenez les prêts et vous le
jeter par la fenêtre
sérieusement merci pour cet exemple
parce que j'ai envie que vous me disiez
aussi à quoi l'avenir va ressembler y
compris en positif parce qu'on n'est pas
non plus simplement en train de se jouer
à se faire peur mais quand même il ya
des petits logiciels qui vous permettent
de suivre vos enfants vous êtes
peut-être regarder ça et dans le
documentaire tout à l'heure c'était
assez joliment mis en scène regarder
ma fille a passé les deux dernières
semaines en france et je pouvais voir où
était son ipad et je soulevais voir
quand il était à paris et quand il était
à marseille puis quand il était en
provence
c'était très rassurant bien sûr le
système dépistage était là aussi avec
son accord c'est un consentement mutuel
là où il ya problème c'est lorsqu'il
n'ya pas consentement
les nouvelles générations d'enfants
chinois comme moi ont fait partie de la
première génération des enfants uniques
lorsqu'on est loin de nos parents à la
maison ma mère mon a déjà parlé elle
peut ouvrir son portable il regarder où
se trouve ce petit point bleu qui me
représente
pour elle ce point bleu ce n'est pas un
simple compte c'est son unique enfant
elle voit mes déplacements ça
l'intéresse c'est ça la rassure
parfois elle me téléphone et elle me dit
alors tu es sur le port de shanghai
je trouve cela bizarre comme on le sait
d'elle c'est parce qu'elle voit mon
petit point bleu sur l'écran
nous sommes tous devenus des petits
points bleus finalement aider vous me
disiez la mère que je suis
heureuse de pouvoir avec leur
consentement et louis et l'enfant
l'enfant que je suis mes parents sont
décédés mais je réussis ça pour savoir
qu'ils ne sont pas tombés que tout va
bien on est trois fois par jour et avec
leur consentement puisque en même temps
il aurait été content de savoir qu'on
peut toujours un terme est ce que ce
n'est pas le mot clé de cette émission
consentement et que finalement il se
passe un nombre de choses changent oui
bien sûr bien sûr mais ce que les
conditions et les technologies évoluent
c'est à dire qu'il faut se rappeler que
ces grands contrats que vous signez avec
facebook avec ses prestataires c'est une
case que vous cochez avec des conditions
générales d'utilisation et en france ils
ne sont que traduction puisqu'on vous
dit bien c'est bien la version en
anglais qui compte est la version en
français et simplifié fait cette page on
voit bien en plus que quelquefois si
vous avez un contentieux c'est un
tribunal en l'occurrence ebay facebook
c'est se sentent à clara en californie
qui est compétent donc le consentement
éclairé de prendre conscience des usages
parce que sur le principe on peut être
d'accord mais c'est de comprendre ah oui
quelles sont les conséquences et donc
que ce soit en confiance le concède la
deuxième option de consentement est ce
qu'elle est toujours elle est toujours
au rendez vous pas quand on échange mais
fichiers en les revendant comme le
disait
mon collègue que leur père de nicolas
exactement
c'est compliqué parce que les les
chartes que doivent signer l'utilisateur
sont extrêmement longues en général on
les lit pas on passe directement au
bouton j'accepte je ne sais même pas ce
qu'il peut se passer plus facilement et
et et le problème aussi c'est qu'on n'a
pas le choix c'est à dire soit on veut
le service et on accepte un jour soit on
se pose des questions en termes de vie
privée est ce que ma vie privée ne peut
pas être infecté justement si je sais
trop facilement mes données personnelles
et la honte avoir de la résistance et la
solution c'est bien sûr de refuser ce
service là et peut-être de se tourner
vers d'autres services qui sont beaucoup
moins gourmand donc devenir un gars qui
est pas sur facebook sur twitter
sur linkedin à fernand c'est qu'on n'est
pas obligé non plus de poser nue et bien
sûr bien sûr les b sens auxerre on peut
communiquer par ses biens sans dire je
suis en ce moment au sénat où je suis
sur la côte d'azur ou à chamonix vous
pouvez aussi utiliser ces instruments
c'est quand même un un choix que vous
pouvez faire de dire je veux où je veux
pas qu'on dise où je suis c'est pas
interdit est-ce que c'est oui ou non un
outil de surveillance générale n'ont à
mon avis non pas de cette façon là parce
qu'il ya un problème qui est la masse
des données et je pense que là ce que
vous évoquez tout on est bien sûr tout à
fait aléatoire des capteurs pour traiter
les séances et attendait globalement on
attendait juste jour et finir soirée est
intéressant c'est que finalement les
coupables entre guillemets c'est plutôt
les gens qui sont capables de faire des
logiciels qui permettent de faire ces
croisements à toute vitesse à moindre
frais et qu'ils permettent de traiter
énormément de données là dessus on va
être bien d'accord mais je crois me
souvenir qu'il ya quand même quelques
avions qui ont disparu qu'on n'a jamais
réussi à localiser s'ils avaient toutes
les baleines et balises qui faisait
qu'il fallait et dieu sait qu'on les a
cherchés et on les a jamais trouvé il ya
quand même un certain nombre de cas et
d'applications où on aimerait bien
savoir si les gens soient réellement un
endroit où ils sont et ce n'est pas
capable de le voir donc ce que je veux
dire c'est qu'il ya à la fois des
parades il ya toujours l'armé de
boucliers le grand danger là dessus je
pense qu'on sera tous d'accord c'est
effectivement un certain nombre
d'applications dérivés se fasse sans
qu'on soit au courant sans qu'on les
voit venir et avec des gens très
astucieux qui font comme ce que vous
appelez des petits logiciels qui
permettent à partir de là de détourner
des données mais c'est plus une question
globale d'un monde interconnecté et d'un
monde utilisant des données que
simplement la question de la
localisation de la géolocalisation qui
me paraît quand même et puis juste un
petit point très très rapide mais ça
m'amuse parce que tout à fait au début
donc le réalisateur dit on tout le monde
sait ce qu'on fait et c'est enfin on a
quand même vécu une époque dans des
villages où le postier arrivé à l'époque
des cartes postales et vous disais voilà
votre cousine pas bête vous a écrit elle
pas bien il fait très beau en corse dont
il faut quand même la hausse et au
regard des raisons sera sur le pont
d'ailleurs l'habitant sur la planète que
tout on n'est pas très peu de la même
façon que tout le monde s'intéresse pas
de la même façon et donc je pense que
c'est un débat qui est extrêmement
intéressant mais qui mérite quand même
d'être assez finement découpées si on
veut pas trop ce qu'on a essayé des
réalités sans caricature vous avez 30
secondes pour me dire la merveille qui
m'attend dans les cinq ans qui viennent
le truc que je n'attends pas moi grâce à
la géolocalisation qui va m'arriver dans
ma vie quotidienne ce qui est certain
c'est la personnalisation c'est à dire
que le l'ambition la promesse ça va être
de faire que en fait avec la logique du
prédictif faire en sorte que si vous
avez fait ça si les gens comme vous qui
ont le même profil on fait ça ça va être
de vous suggérer des endroits et faire
en sorte qu' on puisse vous prévenir à
l'avancé des chemins que vous allez
prendre alors on commence à en voir le
premie r est orange pourra les voir
comme on le voit comment si vous mettez
toutes vos coordonnées dans votre agenda
électronique celui ci peut vous dire
rappelez vous vous êtes aujourd'hui au
sénat vous avez rendez-vous à rtl la
circulation est un peu encombré il faut
partir maintenant parce que c'est le
temps qu'il va falloir vous m la seule
chose c'est que vous voyez bien que tant
que ces consentis ça y va et donc on va
réserver le taxi qui va vous attendre
devant qui va prendre en compte le fait
que vous avez décalage comme on va vous
suivre avec l'avion alors que avec le le
système on va voir que vous saviez vous
mettez un peu de temps à naviguer parmi
les couloirs du sénat est donc que lui
va pouvoir comprendre et et donc
éventuellement
géolocaliser géo diriger la géo et et en
temps réel jean-paul geo est
effectivement aussi sa ruine la notion
de vie privée d'intimité de spontanéité
puisque on l'a vu d'ailleurs avec le
jeune pilote allemand les premiers
réflexes et j'ai été frappé par cette
phrase entendue dans les journaux enfin
dans les médias quelques heures à une
fois qu'on les identifiants l'a dit il
n'a pas de profil facebook et ça c'est
étonnant et c'est vrai que c'est la
question qu'il faut aussi poser de
celles et ceux qui ne seront pas
localisée de celles et ceux qui n'auront
pas été identifiées et 7/10 cette
absence et dissimulation risquerait
d'être même considéré comme étant
suspecte incroyable merci à tous les cas
tous les 5 avec franck cuvellier le
réalisateur qui était avec nous tout à
l'heure réagissez n'hésitez pas à vous
le faites de plus en plus nombreux sur
le mail de l'émission qui s'affiche en
bas de votre écran à très vite sur
public sénat